it's fair to say canadians have never
seen a hike in gas prices quite like
this as i watch the gas go in the car i
see the dollar figure rising almost
twice as quickly as as the leader figure
across the country records are breaking
a dollar 66 a liter in toronto and
halifax may be hard to swallow but look
at montreal at a dollar 79.9
or ottawa at a dollar 94.9
and then there's vancouver which is now
top two dollars a liter for the first
time ever outrageous like 75 bucks
doesn't even like give me
20 kilometers
the war in ukraine is the easy scapegoat
but it's far more complicated than that
any direct or indirect dealings in
russian sovereign debt earlier this week
canada shut its ports to russian cargo
ships a largely symbolic move since
canada hasn't imported much oil from
russia since 2019. a pair of tankers
have already been turned away they are
carrying colombian fuel to irving oil in
new brunswick but the ships themselves
are russian owned this ukraine russia
situation has got everybody just
following the bouncing barrels down the
hill the cost of crude is going through
the roof and the speculation on where
gasoline prices will go and so far the
futures market is concerned
is
just out of control that uncertainty is
playing a big role in driving up prices
if sanctions are expanded to include
russian oil europe which imports 40 of
its gas from russia will have to bid
against the rest of the world including
canada for available supply this is not
a thing where you turn the switch off
and on chocolate or vanilla milkshake
it's uh it's going to take a long time
to get this back on track to make
matters worse what we're seeing in oil
prices today doesn't impact the price at
the pump until next month so fill up now
this is going to be an expensive ride
microlight global news toronto